SAYS "KILLER" AT THE BOTTOM.
AMAZING.
THIS IS HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY, AS YOU KNOW, THERE’S A
REASON FOR IT.
OVER THE WEEKEND, MOST RECENTLY,
THAT WAS A PART OF THIS, CITY
OFFICIALS ANNOUNCED A PLAN TO
REMOVE THE STATUE OF TEDDY
ROOSEVELT OUTSIDE NEW YORK’S
MUSEUM OF NATURAL HISTORY.
THE BRONZE STATUE HAS STOOD
THERE FACING CENTRAL PARK SINCE
BEFORE THE SECOND WORLD WAR.
SOON IT WILL BE GONE.
PEOPLE RECORD THAT STATUE 80
YEARS AGO WOULD BE CONFUSED BY
THIS NO DOUBT.
THEY DID NOT CONSIDER SETTING
ROOSEVELT A CONTROVERSIAL FIGURE
FIGURE.
THE MOST POPULAR PRESIDENT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
ALSO THE MOST AMERICAN
PRESIDENT.
NO OTHER COUNTRY COULD HAVE
PRODUCED TEDDY ROOSEVELT.
HIS VIRTUES MIRRORED THE VALUES
OF AMERICA.
HE WAS PHYSICALLY BRAVE, HE WAS
PROFOUNDLY LITERATE, HIGHLY SELF
DISCIPLINED AND AMAZINGLY
ENERGETIC.
WHILE STILL A COLLEGE STUDENT,
ROOSEVELT WROTE A TWO-VOLUME
HISTORY OF THE WAR OF 1812.
IT IS STILL IN PRINT TODAY, YOU
CAN BUY IT ON AMAZON.
THE YOUNGEST PRESIDENT IN OUR
HISTORY, SAVED OUR ECONOMY FROM
CORPORATE MONOPOLIES AND BY
DOING THAT HE MADE THE AMERICAN
MIDDLE CLASS POSSIBLE.
HE CREATED THE NATIONAL PARKS,
CREATED THE PANAMA CANAL, THE
FOOD AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION,
AND THEN HE KEPT GOING.
THE LIST OF TEDDY ROOSEVELT’S
ACHIEVEMENTS FILLS ENTIRE
SHELVES OF BIOGRAPHIES.
THOSE ARE IN ADDITION TO THE
MORE THAN 40 BOOKS HE WROTE
HIMSELF ON TOPICS RANGING FROM
OLIVER CROMWELL TO CATTLE
RANCHING, TO SOCIAL JUSTICE.
PERSONALLY, ROOSEVELT WAS A
FAMOUSLY DECENT MAN.
IN 1901 HE INVITED HIS FRIEND
BOOKER T. WASHINGTON TO DINNER.
NO AFRICAN-AMERICAN HAD EVER
EATEN IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
DEMOCRATS ROARED WITH THE RAGE
THE IDEA.
THE CRIME OF HAVING A MEAL WITH
A BLACK MAN, THEY ATTACKED TEDDY
ROOSEVELT AND HIS WIFE FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES.
BUT ROOSEVELT NEVER BOWED.
HE GAVE THE FINGER TO THE MOB
AND HE CONTINUED CHEERFULLY ON.
TEDDY ROOSEVELT WAS A HERO TO
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
HE STILL IS.
THAT’S PRECISELY WHY THEY’RE
TEARING DOWN HIS STATUE.
THEY NOTED THEY CAN FORCE YOU TO
WATCH AS THEY TOPPLE YOUR
HEROES, THEY HAVE WON.
THERE IS NOTHING THEY CAN’T DO
NEXT.
THEY CAN DECIDE HOW YOU RAISE
HER CHILDREN, HOW YOU VOTE, WHAT
YOU’RE ALLOWED TO BELIEVE.
ONCE THEY’VE HUMILIATED YOU,
THEY CAN CONTROL YOU, AND THAT’S
WHY ACROSS THE COUNTRY MOBS ARE
TEARING DOWN AMERICA’S
MONUMENTS.
IN THE CITIES OF RICHMOND AND
ST. PAUL, MINNESOTA, THEY TURNED
ON STATUS OF CHRISTOPHER
COLUMBUS.
THEY DID THE SAME THING IN
BOSTON.
BOSTON’S MAYOR ANNOUNCES ITS
TIME TO REMOVE A STATUE OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN, THE MAN WHO
FREED THE SLAVES.
IN DALLAS TO BUILD A TEXAS
RANGER STATUE OUT OF THE AIRPORT
AFTER MORE THAN 50 YEARS.
IN MICHIGAN THE TOP OF THE
STATUE OF THE FORMER MAYOR.
THEY DID THE SAME THING IN
PHILADELPHIA.
IN NASHVILLE THAT PULLED ON A
STATUE OF A FORMER U.S. SENATOR.
IN OREGON, THOMAS JEFFERSON AND
GEORGE WASHINGTON WERE TORN
DOWN.
IT’S AT WITH CISCO, THE MOB
DEMOLISHED STATUES OF
ULYSSES S. GRANT AND FRANCIS
SCOTT KEY.
IN THE PEDESTAL OF THE KEY
MONUMENT THEY SPRAY-PAINTED
"KILLER COLONIZERS" AND "KILL
WHITEY" JUST IN CASE YOU MISSED
THE POINT.
ONE THING ALL OF THESE AMERICANS
NOW CANCEL HAVE IN COMMON, NOT
ONE OF THEM FOUGHT FOR THE
CONFEDERACY.
PULLING DOWN HER STATUES HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
CIVIL WAR.
AT LEAST NOT THE FIRST
CIVIL WAR, THE ONE THAT TOOK
PLACE ON HUNDRED 50 YEARS AGO.
DEMOCRATS UNDERSTAND THAT VERY
WELL AND THEY SUPPORT ALL OF IT.
IN EVERY PLACE WHERE THE MOB HAS
DESTROYED PUBLIC MONUMENTS,
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS HAVE BACKED
THEM AS THEY DID IT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, AND YOU
SHOULD KNOW THIS, SO HAVE MANY
REPUBLICANS.
LAST WEEK I MOB IN DOWNTOWN
WASHINGTON, D.C., CITED TO TEAR
DOWN THE STATUE OF A MAN CALLED
ALBERT PIKE.
PIKE WAS FAMOUS AS A JOURNALIST
AND A POET AND LATER AS A
PROMINENT FREEMASON.
FOR LESS THAN A YEAR FROM LATE
NOVEMBER OF 1861 TO MID-JULY OF
1862, PIKE SERVED IN THE
CONFEDERATE ARMY.
PIKE WAS LATER ARRESTED FOR
TREASON AGAINST THE CONFEDERACY
AND HE FACED EXECUTION FOR THAT.
BUT IN THE END, IT DIDN’T SAVE
HIM FROM THE MOB.
THEY SET FIRE TO HIS APOGEE AS A
LLAMA GROUND.
AT LEAST ONE PROMINENT
CONSERVATIVE TWEETED HIS
APPROVAL OF THIS.
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS SAID
NOTHING AT ALL, AND THEY COULD
HAVE.
PIKE’S NOW DESTROYED STATUE IS
OWNED BY THE NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE.
ITS FEDERAL PROPERTY, TEARING IT
DOWN WAS A FEDERAL CRIME.
BUT NO ONE IN WASHINGTON EVEN
CONSIDERED ENFORCING THE LAW.
KEVIN McCARTHY OF CALIFORNIA,
THE TOP REPUBLICAN HOUSE WAS NOT
IN A POSITION TO SAY MUCH OF
ANYTHING.
McCARTHY HAS ENDORSED THE
REMOVAL OF STATUES AT THE LEFT
HAD DESIGNATED AND RACIST.
LAST WEEK THE DASH KEVIN
McCARTHY REFUSED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT ON HIS OFFICIAL
TWITTER ACCOUNT.
WEDNESDAY, McCARTHY DIDN’T
MANAGE TO SEND A VERY
EMPHATICALLY CALLING FOR
SANCTIONS AGAINST SYRIA.
"TO HOLD THE RESULTS, ASSAD
REGIME RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
ATROCITIES."
ELECTED REPUBLICANS FROM ALMOST
ALL OF THEM, ARE IN NO HURRY TO
STOP THIS DISORDER.
A VERSION OF THE RODNEY
KING RIOTS FROM THE 1992.
PEOPLE SAW UPSETTING VIDEO ON
THE INTERNET, THERE ARE
HUNDREDS, THAT’S INSTANT
EXPANDABLE.
WE CAN GET BACK TO CUTTING
CAPITAL GAINS TAXES AND
SANCTIONED BASHAR AL-ASSAD.
THAT’S THEIR VIEW OF IT.
THEY’RE WRONG.
THIS IS NOT A MOMENTARY CIVIL
DISTURBANCE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS AND HIGHLY
ORGANIZED POLITICAL MOVEMENT.
IT IS NOT SUPERFICIAL, IT IS
DEEP AND PROFOUND, IT HAS VAST
AMBITIONS.
IT IS INSIDIOUS, IT WILL GROW.
ITS GOAL IS TO END LIBERAL
DEMOCRACY AND CHALLENGE WESTERN
CIVILIZATION ITSELF.
THIS IS AN IDEOLOGICAL MOVEMENT.
THE IDEA THAT HAVING GIVEN IT
FOR DECADES ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
WE PAY FOR ALL OF IT, BY THE
WAY.
REST OF US WERE SO THRILLED THAT
OUR KIDS GOT INTRODUCED THAT WE
DECIDED TO IGNORE WHAT DUKE WAS
ACTUALLY TEACHING THEM AND HAS
CONTINUED TO SEND BIG CHECKS.
THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
IF ONE OF THE GREATEST MISTAKES
WE’VE EVER MADE.
WE DIDN’T APPRECIATE THE STAKES
INVOLVED AT THE TIME AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT WE BECAME EASY
MARKS FOR THEIR LIVES.
EVEN NOW, SO MANY OF US CONTINUE
TO PRETEND THAT THIS IS ABOUT
POLICE BRUTALITY BUT THE DEATH
OF A MAN CALLED GEORGE FLOYD IN
MINNEAPOLIS.
WE STILL IMAGINE WE CAN FIX OF A
REGULATING CHOKE HOLD OR
SPENDING MORE ON DE-ESCALATION
TRAINING.
WE ARE TOO LITERAL OR TOO
GOOD-HEARTED TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT’S REALLY HAPPENING.
OUR DECENCY IS THE MOB’S MAIN
WEAPON AGAINST US.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO WE ARE UP
AGAINST.
FOR MOST PEOPLE, THE PRIMARY JOY
IN LIFE IS THE ACT OF CREATION,
MAKING SOMETHING GOOD AND
USEFUL, OTHER IT’S DINNER FOR
YOUR FAMILY OR A DECK OFF THE
BACK OF HER HOUSE OR A SOLID DAY
AT WORK.
THE MOST PROFOUND ACTIVE
CREATION OF COURSES HAVING
CHILDREN.
NEW LIFE ITSELF.
HEALTHY SOCIETIES CELEBRATE ALL
OF THIS.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THE IMPULSE
TO CREATE IS HOW CIVILIZATIONS
ARE BUILT.
BUT THEY ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE FORCES ARRAYED AGAINST
CREATION AND THEY VIGILANTLY
DEFEND THEMSELVES AGAINST THOSE.
IN EVERY SOCIETY THERE ARE THOSE
WHO SEEK TO DESTROY.
THEY DESTROY, FOR THE SAME
REASON THAT TROUBLED BOYS
TORTURE DOGS, OR SHOULD HOUSE
CATS, INFLICTING PAIN MAKES THEM
FEEL POWERFUL.
WE USED TO CALL PEOPLE LIKE THAT
ANTISOCIAL FORCES.
THEY STILL EXIST, WE JUST
PRETEND THEY DON’T.
OR WORSE, WE EXCUSE THEIR
BEHAVIOR, WE CODDLE THEM, WE
FUND THEM.
WALL STREET SENDS THE MONEY IN
THE HOPES THAT THEY WILL BE
DESTROYED LAST.
REST OF US LOOK UPON CONFUSED,
WE DON’T REALLY KNOW WHAT’S
HAPPENING, BUT THE DESTROYERS
KNOW, THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT’S
GOING ON.
NEVER IN AMERICAN HISTORY HAVE
THEY BEEN MORE EMBOLDENED THAN
THEY ARE NOW.
JUST THIS AFTERNOON AROUND
LUNCHTIME AND ACTIVIST CALLED
CHONGQING ISSUED THE FOLLOWING
DEMANDS ON TWITTER.
"ALL MURALS AND STAINED-GLASS
WINDOWS OF WHITE JESUS AND HIS
EUROPEAN MOTHER AND BOYFRIEND
SHOULD ALSO COME DOWN.
A VERY GROSS FORM OF WHITES FROM
US HE TOOLS OF OPPRESSION,
RACIST PROPAGANDA.
THEY SHOULD ALL COME DOWN."
"
BEFORE YOU DISMISS THAT IDEA AS
ABSURD, THE RANTINGS OF SOME
CRANK OF SOCIAL MEDIA, KEEP IN
MIND THAT CHONGQING IS THE MOST
AMOS BLACK LIVES MATTER LEADER
IN THIS COUNTRY.
BLACK LIVES MATTER IS NOW MORE
POPULAR THAN EITHER MAJOR
POLITICAL PARTY.
SO DON’T BE SURPRISED WHEN THEY
COME FOR YOUR CHURCH.
WHY WOULDN’T THEY?
NO ONE IS STOPPING THEM.
THE FORCES OF DESTRUCTION HAVE
GRAND AMBITION.
IT’S NOT JUST ABOUT THE TEDDY
ROOSEVELT STATUE.
THEY PLAN TO RULE THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF THEY DO?
WELL, YOU MAY IMAGINE THAT
SELF-DEFENSE IS YOUR BULWARK
AGAINST CHAOS.
IN THIS COUNTRY YOU ASSUME YOU
CAN ALWAYS DEFEND YOURSELF AND
YOUR FAMILY.
THAT’S A PILLAR OF OUR
CIVILIZATION, OF ALL WESTERN
CIVILIZATION.
THIS WOMAN ASSUMES THAT TOO.
ON WEDNESDAY SHE WAS DRIVING
THROUGH LOUISVILLE, KENTUCKY.
CORDING TO LOCAL POLICE, THE
WOMAN FOUND HERSELF SURROUNDED
BY PROTESTERS WHO WERE ROCKING
THE ROAD.
THEY STOOD IN FRONT OF HER CAR
WITH A MEGAPHONE.
SHE ARGUED WITH THEM TO LET HER
PASS.
ONE OF THEM PRODUCED OR DONE.
THE WOMAN TRIED TO FLEE.
WHERE SHOWING THE DRAMATIC TAPE
ON YOUR SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
LOOK AT IT.
WHEN THE WOMAN STOPPED AT A
RED LIGHT A BLOCK LATER, ANOTHER
PROTESTER POINTED A GUN AT HER
AGAIN.
SHE HIT THE GAS AND MADE IT HOME
ALIVE.
ON SUNDAY, NATIONAL PUBLIC
WRITER PUBLISHED AN ARTICLE
ABOUT THE INCIDENT.
IF THE OF THAT PIECE, VEHICLES
ATTACKS RISE AS EXTREMISTS
TARGET PROTESTERS.
IN OTHER WORDS, FOR TRYING TO
ESCAPE FROM BEING MURDERED, AND
P.R. CALLED THIS WOMAN AN
EXTREMIST WHO WAS "TARGETING
PROTESTERS."
THINK ABOUT THAT AND YOU’LL
BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND WHY SO FEW
CITIZENS HAVE TRIED TO STOP THE
MOB AS THEY PILLAGED OUR
COUNTRY.
ANTIFA DOESN’T OWN THE STATUES
IN YOUR CITY’S PARKS.
IT DOESN’T OWN YOUR CITY, YOU
DO.
YOU HELPED PAY FOR IT.
BUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF YOU TRY
TO DEFEND PUBLIC PROPERTY?
OR EVEN IF YOU TRY TO DEFEND
YOUR OWN PROPERTY?
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER, YOU’D BE
SWARMED BY FEDERAL AGENTS,
ROGER STONED WITH THE HELP AND
COMPLICITY OF CNN AND NPR AND SO
MANY OTHERS.
THERE’S NO QUESTION, YOU’VE SEEN
THIS HAPPEN BEFORE.
TO A REMARKABLE DEGREE, FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT STAR DRIVEN BY
POLITICAL IMPERATIVES.
CERTAIN KINDS OF SO-CALLED
HATE CRIMES TOP THE LIST OF
PRIORITIES.
THEY WILL DRAW THE FBI FASTER
THAN YOU PUT SOME OF THE LOCAL
POLICE TO YOUR HOUSE DURING A
HOME INVASION.
EVEN WHEN, AS IS SO OFTEN THE
CASE, THEY TURN OUT TO BE HOAXES
HOAXES.
MEANWHILE, ACTUAL HATE CRIMES,
BRUTAL CRIMES IN WHICH AMERICANS
ARE GRAVELY INJURED ARE IGNORED
COMPLETELY.
THEY TAKE PLACE ON OUR STREETS
WITH SHOCKING REGULARITY.
I MEAN, THEY DON’T COVER THEM.
THEY OFTEN GO UNPUNISHED
ENTIRELY.
THAT’S NOT SPECULATION.
THERE’S QUITE A BIT OF VIDEO ON
IT ONLINE.
SOME OF IT VERY RECENT.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO SHOW YOU THE
CLIPS.
IF YOU’RE INTERESTED, GO TO THE
TWITTER FEED FOR THE MATT WALSH
BLOG BEFORE TWITTER PULLS IT
DOWN, YOU’LL GET THE POINT.
BUT YOU ALREADY KNOW, LAWS ARE
NOT APPLIED EQUALLY IN AMERICA.
SOME VICTIMS ARE CONSIDERED MORE
DESERVING THAN OTHERS DESPITE
THE FACT WE ARE ALL CITIZENS.
JUSTICE IS NOT BLIND.
NEVER IN OUR LIVES HAS THIS BEEN
MORE TRUE THAN IT IS RIGHT NOW
AND IS VERY LIKELY TO GET WORSE.
THAT’S THE AIM OF THIS MOVEMENT,
OF THESE RIOTS, TO OVERTHROW THE
VALUE, THE PRINCIPAL, OF
EQUALITY UNDER THE LAW.
AFTER NOVEMBER, THAT TREND COULD
ACCELERATE DRAMATICALLY.
AND BY THE LOOK, WE SHOULD STOP
ATTENDING THIS AS AN ELECTION
BETWEEN DONALD TRUMP AND
JOE BIDEN.
THERE IS NO JOE BIDEN.
THE JOE BIDEN YOU REMEMBER NO
LONGER EXISTS.
THE BABBLING HUSK YOU SEE MAY
HAVE THE SAME NAME AND SIMILAR
FEATURES, BUT BEHIND A MASK
THERE IS NOTHING BUT A JUMBLED
COLLECTION OF TALKING POINTS IN
THE EARLY OF US TO BE 70s.
TURN ON YOUR RECORD PLAYER, NO
MORE MALARKEY.
THE CANDIDATE HAS NO INDEPENDENT
THOUGHTS OF HIS OWN.
HE HAS NO CORE BELIEFS.
HE IS EMPTY.
HE IS A PERFECT TROJAN HORSE.
FOR THE PEOPLE HAVE TAKEN OVER
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, HE IS
PERFECT.
THEIR PLAN IS TO WRITE HIM TO
POWER.
ONCE THERE, SOMEONE TOUGH AND
CALCULATING AND PURPOSEFUL,
KAMALA HARRIS, PROBABLY, WILL
CHANGE THE COUNTRY.
HOW?
THEY SHOWED US HOW.
FOR THREE YEARS THEY TOLD US
THAT SECRET RUSSIAN AGENTS HAD
TAKEN OVER THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
THERE WAS NEVER A SINGLE PIECE
OF EVIDENCE TO SHOW THAT THAT
WAS TRUE IN ANY WAY.
IT WAS A HOAX, AND YET IT
WORKED.
THEY DOMINATED THE COUNTRY
WITHOUT LIVE.
AND THAT WAS THEIR DRY RUN.
CAN WE CONVINCE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE TO BELIEVE SOMETHING
THAT’S COMPLETELY ABSURD?
YES WE CAN.
THAT’S WHAT THEY LEARN.
THAT’S THE LESSON.
THEY’LL DO IT AGAIN.
THIS TIME, THE RUSSIANS WILL BE
CONFEDERATE SYMPATHIZERS OR
NAZIS OR WHAT’S A PHARMACIST, OR
WHATEVER OTHER NAME THAT YOU
STILL GET TO THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
IT DOESN’T MATTER.
BUT ONCE THEY PICK WHEN THEY
WILL GIN UP MASS HYSTERIA,
BECAUSE THE WHAT THEY ARE GOOD
AT.
AND WE WILL HAVE ANOTHER
WITCH HUNT.
ONCE AGAIN WITH THE FULL SUPPORT
OF FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
AND WHO KNOWS, MAYBE THE
MILITARY TOO BECAUSE THE THREAT
IS JUST THAT PROFOUND.
A FEW FOOLISH SOULS WILL ATTEMPT
TO POINT OF THE OBVIOUS, WHAT’S
TRUE.
OF COURSE THERE ARE RACISTS
HERE, AS THERE ARE EVERYWHERE,
BUT OVERALL THIS IS THE LEAST
RACIST COUNTRY IN THE HISTORY OF
THE WORLD.
MILLIONS OF AFRICANS WANT TO
MOVE HERE, MANY ALREADY HAVE.
OUR LAST PRESIDENT WAS BLACK.
YOU TALKING ABOUT?
THOSE PEOPLE WILL BE SILENCED.
ANYONE WHO DEFIES THE NARRATIVE
WILL BE SILENCED.
BY THAT POINT, THE CATEGORY OF
HATE SPEECH WILL HAVE EXPANDED
TO INCLUDE ANYTHING THEY DON’T
WANT TO HEAR AND IT WILL BE
CRIMINALIZED, A FEDERAL OFFENSE.
YOU WATCH.
IF THEY CAN TEAR DOWN THE
LINCOLN STATUE BECAUSE IT’S
RACIST, THEY CAN BAN THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
IF YOU DON’T WANT TO LIVE IN A
PLACE LIKE THAT.
WHO CAN SAVE US FROM THAT?
WELL, AS OF RIGHT NOW, ONLY
REPUBLICANS CAN SAVE US FROM
THAT.
NOT BECAUSE THEY’RE INHERENTLY
VIRTUOUS, NOT BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO, THEY DON’T, BUT BECAUSE
THEY’RE THE OPPOSITION PARTY TO
THE EXTENT THEY STILL HAVE
OPPOSITION TO ANYTHING.
WE HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO ASK FOR
THEIR HELP.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS THE ONLY
POWER CENTER LEFT IN THIS
COUNTRY AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WHO
DISSENTS.
IT DOESN’T MATTER WHO YOU VOTED
FOR LAST TIME.
THIS IS NOT AN ENDORSEMENT OF
ANYONE’S POLICIES, IT’S IN ITS
KNOWLEDGE MEANT OF WHO HOLDS
POWER AND WHO DOESN’T ON THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS THE ONLY
POWER CENTER AVAILABLE.
ON FRIDAY, "THE DAILY CALLER"
INTERVIEWED DONALD TRUMP AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
ASK THE PRESIDENT WHY HE HASN’T
SENT FEDERAL TROOPS TO STOP THE
CHAOS IN CITIES LIKE SEATTLE.
HERE’S THE PRESIDENT ANSWERED.
", RIGHT NOW I THINK IT’S GREAT,
SITTING BACK AND WATCHING THIS
CATASTROPHE."
WE UNDERSTAND THE POINT HE WAS
MAKING.
THESE ARE LIBERAL CITIES AND ARE
DESTROYING THEMSELVES.
THEIR POLICIES DON’T WORK, THIS
IS WHAT YOU GET WHEN YOU VOTE
FOR LIBERALS.
BUT IT’S STILL THE WRONG ANSWER.
A PRESIDENT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALL AMERICANS, NO MATTER WHERE
THEY LIVE, FOR THE COUNTRY
ITSELF.
IMAGINE IF YOU HAD A BETTER
ARGUMENT WITH ONE OF HER
CHILDREN.
THE KID RUNS OUT OF THE HOUSE
AND THEN GOES COMPLETE THAT THE
DEFENDANT BECOMES A HEROIN
ADDICT LIVING IN THE STREETS.
BUT YOU DON’T LOOK FOR HIM.
YOU DON’T TRY AND SAVE THEM.
INSTEAD, YOU BRAG THAT HIS DRUG
ADDICTION IS PROOF, YOU WERE
RIGHT ALL ALONG.
RIGHT NOW I THINK IT’S GREAT
WATCHING BACK THIS CATASTROPHE.
HE WOULDN’T SAY THAT, NO GOOD
PARENT WOULD SAY THAT.
NO PRESIDENT SHOULD SAY IT
EITHER.
WE NEED HELP AND WE NEED IT
RIGHT NOW.
THESE ARE NOT PROTESTS, THIS IS